MARK: HELLO AMERICA, I AM MARK
LEVIN, THIS IS "LIFE, LIBERTY
AND LEVIN," WE'LL DO SOMETHING
HERE THAT I DON'T THINK IS
TYPICALLY DONE ON TELEVISION.
BEFORE I BRING ON OUR TWO GREAT
GUESTS.
I WANT TO HAVE A CHAT WITH YOU.
LOOK AT WHAT IS GOING ON IN THE
SCHOOL SYSTEM, THE ABUSE OUR
CHILDREN ARE TAKING.
WE HAVE FEDERAL BUREAUCRATS,
WHETHER MEDICAL OR EDUCATIONAL,
TELLING OUR CHARGE.
THEY ARE GOING TO WEAR A MASK
EVEN THOUGH SCIENCE DOES NOT
SUPPORT IT, EVEN THOUGH SCIENCE
SHOWS US.
IF WE DON'T DEFEND OUR CHILDREN
AND STAND UP FOR OUR CHILDREN,
WHAT USE ARE WE?
WE DIDN'T TURN OUR CHILDREN OVER
TO THE GOVERNMENT.
WE DIDN'T TURN THEM OVER TO
SCHOOL SYSTEMS OR TO THE
TEACHERS UNIONS, THAT IS WHAT I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT BRIEFLY.
AMERICAN MARXISM, THANK YOU OVER
600,000 COPIES SOLD IN OVER TWO
WEEKS.
IT IS NOT BECAUSE MY NAME IS ON
THIS.
IT NOT BECAUSE I AM ON FOX OR
RADIO.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE ON FOX
AND RADIO IS BOOKS.
WHY IS THIS IS A RUN AWAY
BESTSELLER?
IT IS NOT ME, IT IS BECAUSE OF
YOU, THE CONTENTS OF THE BOOK,
AMERICAN MARXISM.
THE LAST CHAPTER I HAVE A
SECTION, WE CHOOSE LIBERTY AND
EDUCATION.
NOW WE NEED TO ADDRESS THIS.
I AM THRILLED THAT PARENT ARE
SHOWING UP IN NUMBERS AT SCHOOL
BOARD MEETINGS THEY ARE ABUSED.
THE ENTRENCHED UNIONS AND
EDUCATIONAL BUREAUCRACY AND
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS, THE CABAL,
THEY HAVE NO INTENTION OF DOING
WHAT WE DEMAND.
THEY CALL IT PUBLIC EDUCATION,
YET WE HAVE NO SAY IN ANYTHING
THAT TAKES PLACE, NOT EVEN
TRANSPARENCY, IT HAS TO END, I
HAVE A PLAN.
A PLAN, NOT JUST FOR PARENTS BUT
FOR THOSE OF US WHO CARE --
TAXPAYERS, GRANDCHILDREN.
IT IS THIS.
COUPLE THINGS.
WE NEED TO ADOPT STRATEGIES OF
LEFT IN SOME RESPECTS.
THEY HAVE AN -- WE COULD USE
BOYCOTT DIVESTMENT AND SANCTIONS
TOO, AGAIN INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE
UNDERMINING OUR COUNTRY, AND
DESTROYING OUR CHILDREN.
WE COULD APPLY IT TO STATE AND
LOCAL AFFILIATES?
WE HAVE THE POWER OF FREEDOM OF
INFORMATION ACT IN EVERY DAY.
WE SHOULD USE THAT IN EVERY
STATE.
FOR WHAT?
HOW DO THEY HIRE TEACHERS?
PROMOTE TEACHERS, WHAT IS IN THE
CONTRACT WITH THE TEACHER UNION.
IN THE SCHOOLS, ASSUMING THOSE
COMPUTERS AND LAPTOPS AND
TELEPHONES HAVE BEEN GIVEN OR
LEASED BY THEM, BY THE SCHOOL
SYSTEM.
THAT IS COVERED BY FOIA.
IT IS TIME TO DIG IN.
NOT JUST FROM OUTSIDE AND
PROTEST, I'M FOR THAT, BUT IT IS
TIME TO GET TACTICAL.
HOW ARE THE BUDGETS DECIDED?
THE SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS, THEY
HAVE THE EXECUTIVE SESSIONS,
WHY?
WHAT IS DISCUSSED THERE?
AND LAWSUITS CAN BE BROUGHT.
THERE ARE EXPENSIVE BUT THERE
ARE LEGAL GROUPS, I HAVE LINKS
AND CONTACTS IN LAST CHAPTER OF
THE BOOK.
THE CIVIL RIGHT ACT IN 1964,
AMENDED EDUCATION, AND 1972.
YOUR CHILDREN ARE NOT SUPPOSED
TO BE SUBJECTED TO A HOSTILE
EDUCATIONAL ENVIRONMENT THAT
PREACHES, THAT INDOCTRINATES
ABOUT RACIAL STEREOTYPES.
WE NEED TO BE -- IF YOUR KID IS
BEING TAUGHT BY A TEACHER WHO IS
TEACHING THEM MARXISM, AND LOUIS
FARRAKHANNISM, DRESSED UP AS
CRITICAL RACE THEORY, YOU SAY, I
DON'T WANT MY KID TAUGHT BY THAT
TEACHER, PERIOD.
WHAT KIND OF TRAINING MATERIALS
ARE GIVEN TO TEACHERS?
YOU HAVE A RIGHT TO FOIA THAT
INFORMATION TOO.
CLOUDARD AND PIVON, OVERWHELM
THE SYSTEM, GET ALL OF THE
INFORMATION, FINDING OUT WHAT IS
GOING ON.
BUT OTHER SHOE.
MANY YEARS AGO, WHEN I WAS
PRESIDENT OF LAND MARK LEGAL
FOUNDATION.
WE FILED COMPLAINS WITH THE
INTERNAL REVENUE SERVICE.
AGAINST THE NATIONAL EDUCATION
ASSOCIATION AND A NUMBER OF THE
STATE AFFILIATES.
A LOT.
YOU CAN DO THIS TOO.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE A LAWYER,
IT'S TIME TO LIBERATE YOUR
SCHOOL SYSTEMS TO PREVENT THEM
42 FROM BEING PLAY THINGS, HERE
IS A COMPLAIN FILED AGAINST
YEARS AGO.
THE UNIONS ARE REQUIRED TO FILE
A INTERNAL REVENUE SERVICE TACKX
FORM AND PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION ON THEIR WEB SITES,
IF THEY DON'T, THEY ARE
VIOLATING THE INTERNAL REVENUE
SERVICE CODE, YOU COULD STILL
CONTACT THEM AND DEMAND A COPY.
WHAT ABOUT THAT FORM?
THEY ARE REQUIRED TO PROVIDE THE
GOVERNMENT WITH CERTAIN MILLION
POLITICAL EXPENDITURES THEY ARE
USING, SO IT IS PUBLIC TO YOU.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING WITH MONEYS
AND DUES, IF THEY ARE FULLY
ACCOUNTED FOR.
WE FOUND IN LANDMARK LEGAL, IT
IS NOT.
YOU HAVE INDIRECT CONTRIBUTIONS
AND INKIND CONTRIBUTIONS THAT
ARE NOT REPORTED, POLITICAL
EXPENDITURES ARE NOT LIMITED TO
MONEY, BUT INCLUDE COST OF USING
A FOLLOW, PERSON NIL --
FACILITY, PERSONNEL, EQUIPMENT.
HOW DO YOU FIND THIS OUT?
FOIA.
HOW ELSE, THE INTERNET, A LOT OF
TIMES THEY CONFESS TO THE THINGS
THEY ARE DOING, THE TIME SPEND
BY AN ORGANIZATION EMPLOYEES
DIRECTING VOLUNTEER CAMPAIGN
EFFORTS, MUST BE ACCOUNTED FOR.
MARK, THIS IS TOO MUCH
INFORMATION, THIS IS GREAT !
LOOK AT NEWSPAPER ARTICLES AND
PRESS RELEASE.
SEE HOW MUCH TIME THEY ARE
INVOLVED IN POLITICAL
ACTIVITIES, THEY ARE COORDINATED
WITH THE PARTIES.
OR COORDINATED WITH OTHER UNION
AND SO FORTH THAT IS TO BE
REPORTED.
ON THEIR TAX RETURNS, AND RARELY
IS.
NE-- DOES NOT REPORT ON 990,
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO.
YOU DID ON, YOU ARE TRYING TO
ALSO SHOW, THEY ARE NOT
REPORTING ALL MONEYS FROM
GENERAL OPERATING FUNDS, WHAT
ELSE?
DEMONSTRATE THE USE OF TAX
EXEMPT RESOURCES THAT SUPPORT
POLITICAL ACTIVITIES.
FUNNELING GENERAL REVENUES TO
USES FUNDS -- YOU CAN LOOK FOR
THIS.
THEY HAVE TO REPORTER PLUG
NICKEL THEY OF USING FOR
POLITICAL PURPOSES, THEY ARE
SLOPPY.
THEY ARE ARROGANT.
THE OTHER THING ON THEIR WEB
SITE, AND PRESS RELEASES, THEY
TOLD BUT THESE POLITICAL THINGS
THEY ARE DOING.
THEY COP THAT'S INFORMATION
COMPARE TO TAX RETURNS, I SAID,
WE SHOULD CREATE COMMUNITY
COMMITTEES.
IN THE COMMITTEES, MAYBE A LOCAL
ACCOUNT OR A LOCAL LAWYER OR
HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE WANT TO DIG
IN.
COMPARE WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
TO WHAT THEY ARE REPORTING.
THE INFORMATION IS OUT THERE
NOBODY LOOKING AT IT.
NEA AND STATE AFFILIATES MUST
COMPLY FULLY WITH REPORTS
REQUIREMENTS, IRS ENFORCEMENT OF
INTERNAL REVENUE SERVICE CODE,
ENABLES PUBLIC MEMBERS AND
NONMEMBER FEED PAYERS TO RECEIVE
ACCURATE INFORMATION.
THE EVIDENCE IN THE COMPLAIN.
IS THEY FAILED TO DISCLOSE THE
FULL EXTENT OF THEIR POLITICAL
ACTIVITIES.
I'M NOT GOING TO READ IT ALL.
YOU HAVE TOOLS AT YOUR FINGER
TIPS, THINK OUTSIDE OF THE BOX.
I HELP NEW "AMERICAN MARXISM" IN
THE BACK OF THE BOOK.
THIS IS JUST IN RESPECT TO
UNIONS, THEY SAID WE'RE TEACHING
CRITICAL RACE THEORY WHETHER YOU
LIKE IT OR NOT, I AM SURE THEY
ARE WORKING WITH CDC TO REQUIRE
YOUR KIDS TO WEAR FACE MASKS,
THEY DID THAT TWO MONTHS AGO.
THE UNIONS ARE AT WAR WITH YOUR
KIDS AND WITH PARENTS AND OUR
COMMUNITIES, WE'RE SUBSIDIZING
THE WHOLE DAMN THING, HUNDREDS
OF BILLIONS A YEAR, WE DON'T RUN
OUR SCHOOL SIMMS, THEY RUNT
SCHOOL SYSTEMS, WHO ARE THEY?
>> YOU DON'T AGREE WITH THEM.
I'M NOT TELLING YOU ABOUT EVERY
INDIVIDUAL TYPE OF EVERY, I AM
TALKING ABOUT THE -- TEACHER,
BUT THE INSTITUTION OF PUBLIC
SECTOR TEACHER UNIONS, THEY ARE
THE ENEMY OF PUBLIC EDUCATION,
THEY FIGHT SCHOOL CHOICE IN THE
INNER-CITY, THEY DEMAND TENURE.
THEY DEMAND PAY RAISES.
AND I CAN GO DOWN THE LIST, I
KNOW I'M NOT GOING TO BE MOST
POPULAR INDIVIDUAL IN THE WORK
WITH TEACHERS, BUT I WANT
TEACHERS TO UNDERSTAND, I AM NOT
ATTACKING YOU, MANY DON'T WANT
TO BE ASSOCIATED WITH THESE
UNIONS, JOE BIDEN WANTS TO GET
RID OF RIGHT TO WORK LAWS IN
EVERY STATE, EVERY STATE, THE
PUBLIC SECTOR EMPLOYEES ARE
UNIONIZED AND THE INDIVIDUAL
TEACHERS CANNOT BREAK FREE.
THERE IS A LOT WE CAN DO.
THERE IS A LOT WITH LITIGATION,
AND FOIA AND PROTESTS AND
INTERNAL REVENUE SERVICE, THERE
IS A LOT WE CAN DO, GETTING
CAMERAS IN CLASSROOM IS
CRITICAL, NEXT TIME THAT
CONTRACT COMES UP WITH TEACHER
UNION, YOU WANT THOSE CAMERAS,
IF THEY THREATEN TO STRIKE, MOVE
YOUR KIDS, AT LEAST TEMPORARILY,
THIS IS A BATTLE WORTH FIGHTING
AND WINNING, THIS IS ONE AREA TO
DISCUSS.
TOUGH TO DO IT IN 10 MINUTES,
CHECK IT OUT IN "AMERICAN
MARXISM."
WE DON'T HAVE TO TAKE IT THESE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WE SUBSIDIZE
DIRECTLY AND INDIRECTLY, THEY
ARE SUPPOSED TO WORK FOR US,
WE'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO WORK FOR
THEM, DO YOU LIKE THE EDUCATION
YOUR CHILDREN ARE GETTING?
DO YOU LIKE THE FACT TEST SCORES
ARE DROPPING AND THEY'RE TAUGHT
RADICAL IDEOLOGIES AND TEACHERS
UNION TELLS THEM, YOU HAVE TO
TAKE IT AND YOUR TAX BILL COMES
EVERY YEAR, THE PROPERTY TAXES,
YOU PAYS, IF YOU DON'T PAY THEY
TA